President Trump has officially been
acquitted in the Senate's farce
impeachment trial but not before
snake-in-the-grass Mitt Romney gets in
one last little nip before being
relegated to ignominy and obscurity we
will compare sanctimonious backstabbers
with serious and successful
conservatives then the Trump
administration leaks a draft of perhaps
the single most important executive
order we will see in our lifetimes to
make America beautiful again finally
Andrew yang reminds us why the left no
matter how eccentric should never be
trusted all that more i'm michael
knowles and this is the michael Knowles
show
[Music]
this is the way impeachment ends not
with a bang but a whimper it's over the
president has been acquitted we all knew
that that was going to happen and now it
happened now it's over
and we can move on but before it was
over at that very last moment MIT
freakin Romney had to get in one last
little jab at the president so there
were two charges for against the
president there was the charge of abuse
of power and then obstruction of
Congress there was no charge of any
crime the the House Democrats were
considering a third charge of bribery
which would be the only impeachable
offense they dropped that because they
didn't have evidence on the charge of
abuse of power the final vote was 52 to
48 52 to acquit the president 48 to
convicted on the charge of obstruction
of Congress the final vote was 53 to 47
now there are 535 members of Congress
there are 435 members in the house there
are 100 members in the Senate the reason
that those two two votes were different
is because Mitt Romney voted to convict
the President on abuse of power and Mitt
Romney did that because Mitt Romney
hates Trump here is Romney's reasoning
the Constitution established the vehicle
of impeachment that has occupied both
houses of our Congress these many days
we have labored to faithfully execute
our responsibilities to it we have
arrived at different judgments but I
hope we respect each other's good faith
the allegations made in the articles of
impeachment are very serious as a
senator juror I swore an oath before God
to exercise impartial justice I am
profoundly religious my faith is at the
heart of Who I am I take an oath before
God as enormous ly consequential
I knew from the outset that being tasked
with judging the president the leader of
my own party would be the most difficult
decision I have ever faced I was not
wrong the most difficult decision that
st. MIT would ever face the principled
conservative the true conservative not
like that fraud Donald Trump why did
Mitt Romney do this the reason this
matters this one vote matters obviously
it's not going to determine whether or
not the president gets acquitted but the
reason that it matters is it means that
the Democrats can now say that this was
a bipartisan impeachment in the house
when the House passed the articles of
impeachment no Republicans voted for it
cuz there weren't any snakes in the
grass like Mitt Romney so it was all the
Democrats voting for impeachment and
Democrats and Republicans voting against
impeachment in the house then you get to
the Senate and it was a completely party
line vote the conservative Democrats
didn't come over and the squishy
Republicans didn't go over to the other
side with the exception of that
sanctimonious snake in the grass
MIT Romney in 2012 I had the distinction
of working on the campaign's of two of
Mitt Romney's primary challengers I have
been calling Mitt Romney a snake in the
grass for a very long time and I've
never felt prouder of that intuition and
decision we will get to the principled
Mitt Romney dating all the way back to
the 90s because film and the Internet
are forever we will get to this
wonderful maybe the most conservative
executive order that any president has
ever issued or leaked to possibly issue
first though I've got to thank our
friends over at stamps.com
with stamps calm you save five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40
percent off shipping rates that kind of
savings can really add up especially for
small businesses stamps.com brings all
the services of the US Postal Service
right to your computer we absolutely
love it over at the Daily wire I love it
personally stamps comm is so great I'm a
millennial I don't want to leave my
couch I don't want to get up and have to
physically go to a place and wait in
line nobody's trying to do that you can
do it all from your computer right now
my listeners get a special offer
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital skill without any
long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com then this is very important
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Noel's ko wles
you will not regret it it will save you
time it will save you money it will make
your life so much easier especially if
you're a small business but even if
you're an individual that is stamps calm
and then click the little microphone and
you enter Noel's ko wles
the principled Mitt Romney had to he had
to vote for these bogus charges of
impeachment that no other Republican
bought at all because they were
ridiculous they were historic the
Democrats couldn't even charge the
president with a crime couldn't even
charge him with an impeachable offense
but the lone conservative Mitt Romney
realized how important it was to convict
he didn't it has nothing to do with
principles at all Mitt Romney just hates
Trump he hates Trump because Trump
became the president and Romney didn't
become the president because he was a
flawed candidate Mitt Romney has
flip-flopped and sold his principles at
every single turn in his political
career which is fine politicians do that
I actually give them a lot of grace on
it but the trouble about Romney is he's
just so damn sanctimonious about him
let's take a little trip down memory
line to the principled MIT Romney
running for Senate against Ted Kennedy
in the 90s he's asked about the legacy
of Ronald Reagan that other other actual
true conservative and what is Romney say
does he say I'm inheriting the mantle of
Ronald Reagan no he says I was not a
conservative during Reagan Bush I was an
independent during Reagan Bush look I
was an independent during the time of
Reagan Bush I'm not trying to return to
Reagan Bush so I don't want to return to
that you kidding me I'm a principled
conservative I don't want to go back to
the policies of Ronald Reagan how about
on other issues yep get past just a
politician like Ronald Reagan how about
on issues like say abortion
here's Mitt Romney true conservative
capital T capital C trademark over the e
back in the day I believe that abortion
should be safe and legal in this country
I have since the time that my mom took
that position when she ran in 1970 as
US Senate candidate I believe that since
roe v wade has been the law for twenty
years that we should sustain and support
it and i sustain and support that law
and the right of a woman to make that
choice
that's Mitt Romney he supports the right
of women to make that choice now
I'll point out Donald Trump held the
same position on abortion back in the
late 90s back when President Trump was
considering running for the Reform Party
nomination what's the difference here
Donald Trump was asked about is his
flip-flop on it he said yeah I changed
my mind I used to have this opinion then
I realized I was wrong and I changed my
mind
Trump for all of his flaws doesn't get
sanctimonious if anything he plays the
sanctimony down a little bit he doesn't
pretend to be very pious and very
principled all the time
he just says yeah I changed my mind I
didn't know a whole lot about the issue
now now I've I've learned about it Mitt
Romney who cast the lone Republican vote
against President Trump he didn't always
publicly hate President Trump actually
back when he ran in 2012 he welcomed
president Trump's endorsement here's
just a little clip there are some things
that you just can't imagine happening in
your life this is one of them being in
Donald Trump's magnificent hotel and
having his endorsement is a delight I'm
so honored and pleased to have his
endorsement and of course I'm looking
for the endorsement of the people of
Nevada Trump has shown an extraordinary
ability to understand how our economy
works to create jobs for the American
people he's done it here in Nevada he's
done it across the country
he understands that our economy is
facing threats from abroad he's one of
the few people who stood up and said you
know what China has been cheating
they've they've taken jobs from
Americans they haven't played fair we
have to have a president who will stand
up to cheaters I spent my life in the
private sector not quite as successful
as this guy but successful nonetheless
sufficiently successful to understand
what it takes to get America to be the
most attractive place in the world for
innovators entrepreneurs and business
and job creators so I want to say thank
you to Donald Trump for his endorsement
it means a great deal to me to have the
endorse
mr. Trump and people across this country
who care about the future of America it
means a great deal to get Donald Trump's
endorsement means a great deal to him
it's such an honor because Donald Trump
has done a whole lot better in business
than Mitt Romney not my words Mets
because Donald Trump beyond his business
success has a keen understanding of our
economic problems he is a key and
understanding of our foreign policy this
was no ordinary endorsement when when
Trump agrees to endorse Romney Romney
gets up there and gives a full-throated
endorsement right back
of Donald Trump because Romney was
getting something for for it at the time
because Romney was personally benefiting
from it so he just said words but then
later on not what three four years later
he contradicted every single one of
those words Donald Trump is a phony a
fraud his promises are as worthless as a
degree from Trump University his
domestic policies would lead to
recession his foreign policies would
make America and the world less safe he
has neither the temperament nor the
judgment to be President and his
personal qualities would mean that
America would cease to be a shining city
on a hill
his bankruptcies have crushed small
businesses and the men and women who
work for them he inherited his business
he didn't create it and whatever
happened to trump Airlines how about
Trump University
and then there's Trump magazine and
Trump vodka and Trump steaks and Trump
mortgage a business genius he is not
well he was more successful in business
than you met that's according to your
own words from three years earlier so
what does that make you if Trump isn't a
business genius then are you a business
dunce
no you're just disingenuous it's it's an
amazing speech that he gave during the
2016 election because it's not just that
he says hey I really don't like this guy
I think he's bad news I think he's bad
for the Republican Party he's bad for
the office of the president he doesn't
just say that that would be at least
defensible it's an election camp
people say a lot of things he he goes
through his past endorsement of Donald
Trump point by point and says the
opposite of everything he said then
three four years earlier he said Donald
Trump is a great businessman a better
businessman than me then he says Donald
Trump is a business failure reason there
was nothing about business he's a fraud
three years four years earlier he said
Donald Trump knows how to deal with
China knows how to deal with our foreign
adversaries four years later what's he
say Donald Trump's foreign policy would
be a disaster four years earlier he says
Donald Trump's economic policies are
wonderful he has a keen understanding of
the economy four years later Donald
Trump's economic policies would lead to
recession point by point by point so he
was either lying then in 2012 or he was
lying in 2016 or somewhere in that three
or four year period everything wonderful
about Donald Trump that Mitt Romney had
praised completely fell apart which one
wasn't which do you think Romney has
done this his entire career so he goes
after Trump II lambaste s-- him in the
2016 election but then that's not the
end of the story
Mitt Romney then goes back and thanks
the president embraces the president's
support when he was running for Senator
in Utah just a couple years ago he
tweeted out quote Thank You mr.
president for the support I hope that
over the course of the campaign I also
earned the support and endorsement of
the people of Utah well if he's a fraud
if he's a disaster if he's a conman why
the hell would you welcome his support
you welcome the support of con men who
would destroy our country who would lead
us into foreign chaos who would whose
economic policies would lead to
recession who's defrauded people for his
whole career you welcome the support of
that kind of man of course he does
because Trump was popular Trump won the
election and Romney is just a
glad-handing politician okay fine
politicians
politics makes strange bedfellows I
understand that the problem here is with
MIT's sanctimony you know I saw this in
2012 I just knew it the guy was an empty
suit that's fine there are a lot of
politicians who are empty suits but then
don't stand up there and pretend to be
the standard-bearer of conservatism to
pretend to be purer than the newly
driven snow mit romney certainly does
not get that and he is his vote was pure
vindictiveness because it doesn't matter
to history it doesn't look the
president's gonna be acquitted it has
nothing to do with the arguments the
house impeachment managers did not make
a single argument that the president
committed an impeachable offense not one
they didn't even try it matters because
he had to get that last nip it the only
thing that Mitt Romney had the power to
do was to try to make it look as though
this was a bipartisan impeachment
process 535 members of Congress one
republican that one republican was the
one who voted for this and i don't think
it was at a principles i think it was
that of petty personal animosity but
that's fine is we're just moving right
along and there was a news report last
night that president Trump is
considering issuing an executive order
that no one's really going to talk about
it's actually only being discussed in
architectural blogs but it is maybe the
most important executive order of my
lifetime that we will ever see we'll get
to that in a second first I have got to
ask you a favor
as you know we rely in part on our
advertisers to keep the mic hot and the
lights on one thing that is very
important for us is that we know who is
listening that's how we make sure that
we're featuring advertisers that you
weren't to do business with so if you
have just a few minutes to spare I would
really appreciate it if you would visit
the pod survey com to fill out a short
survey about yourself once we have
enough information that helps us find
advertisers who you want to hear from so
visit the pod survey Dodd Carmen we'll
take just a few minutes and you know
what you got five minutes don't you come
on we all have five minutes
just complete the survey and please help
my team bring you advertisers who you
want to hear from this executive order
the president Trump is considering is
called the make federal buildings
beautiful again executive order we've
got make America great again now we've
got make America beautiful again
now who cares about federal buildings I
do I care a lot I have been in
Washington DC for three weeks now
filming the verdict podcast with Ted
Cruz and it's wonderful I I love being
in Washington because in certain areas
of DC the architecture is really
beautiful you walk by the White House
you walk by Treasury you walk by all of
these beautiful classical buildings and
you say wow this is grand I feel good
about my country I like seeing beautiful
things and then parts of DC you walk by
some of the buildings that were built in
the 60s 70s 80s and they're hideous
they're just ugly buildings some built
in that brutalist style of architecture
which is just ugly president Trump is
considering passing an executive order
mandating a return to classical
architectural style for federal
buildings he wants to stop wasting your
taxpayer money on ugly buildings and I
could not be more pleased about it so
the draft of the executive order is the
classical architectural style shall be
the preferred and default style for new
and upgraded federal buildings it
suggests that we should have buildings
that remind us of the classical models
of democratic Athens and Republican Rome
and we had this for the early buildings
in Washington DC and then a bunch of
lunatics decided to make everything ugly
in the 60s and 70s in 1962 this the
federal government issued the guiding
principles for federal architecture and
what the guiding principles said was
that quote an official style must be
avoided went on it said design must flow
from the architectural profession to the
government and not vice-versa
so whatever artists want to make of our
federal building
that's what they should be able to make
now of course that doesn't make sense
because the federal government is hiring
the artists but what what the order more
or less said was federal buildings
should look hip and modern and
avant-garde and hideous so the draft the
draft document uses these words dignity
Enterprise vigor stability and declares
officially that brutalist and
deconstructivist styles of architecture
there was just ugly styles from the 70s
quote failed to satisfy these
requirements and shall not be used I
love this you know the great Roger
Scruton who just died recently but he
was maybe the greatest living
conservative philosopher he didn't spend
all this time talking about tax policy
or certain political issues he talked
about beauty Edmund Burke who was the
first modern conservative philosopher he
was an aesthetic philosopher he was a
philosopher of beauty Roger Scruton said
that the way to make people want to
conserve their culture in their country
is to give them beautiful places to live
in a great example of this is when you
get into New York if you get into New
York on the east side you enter Grand
Central Station its grand it's big it's
built in the beaux-arts style of
architecture ornamented grand he walk in
there and you feel like a king on the
other side of town on the west side you
get into the new Penn Station which is
underground it's cramped it's ugly
there's nothing ornate or beautiful
about it there's nothing clean or
classical about it it's just gross and
you enter New York at Penn feeling like
a rat those are the differences it
actually matters I mean I think
conservatives were so pragmatic
sometimes that we just we just care
about lowering our taxes get to keep our
guns and moving on with our lives but
when we look around us that affects how
we feel are in our environment affects
how we feel how we behave how we feel
about ourselves and about our country
there's a reason people come from all
over the country to look at those big
beautiful buildings in Washington DC
they don't go over to those ugly
brutalist office buildings
do they what this shows me ray relates
to the point on MIT Romney is that
Donald Trump gets it whether he drafted
this or he told some guy to draft this
or he merely hired the guy who drafted
this in the White House there is an
understanding or an intuition of a real
depth of conservatism here that
technocrat liberals like Mitt Romney
just do not do not possess or not
capable of possessing I would say other
than saving all those babies which
President Trump's policies have done
he's been the most pro-life president
we've ever had and every one of those
human lives that saved those innocent
lives that are saved because of those
policies are worth more than every
building in the world but other than
that work this could be the most
important thing that the president does
by making America beautiful again it
changes our perspective on how we look
at it there's a relationship between the
good the true and the beautiful I so so
strongly encourage President Trump to
come out with his executive order you
know I never asked anything of you write
your Congressman I mean this is so
important it's so out of the box no
other conservative politician in my
lifetime has suggested anything like it
and it really really matters because
beauty matters and I guess Trump would
be the guy to do this because Trump's a
real estate developer it's but he spent
his own career doing and if that is
frankly that is all we get out of the
Trump administration if he doesn't even
build the wall but he just builds
beautiful buildings in Washington DC
that would be a major major win we've
got to get to Andrew yang reminding us
not to trust the left even when they
were kind of funny and eccentric but
first back in July of last year I told
you about this show Apollo 11 what we
saw the host our pal bill Whittle took
you back in time to what it was like to
live through the Space Age and one of
the greatest endeavors of mankind the
moon landing now bill has hosted a new
season of that show the new season is
the Cold War what we saw if you are
highfalutin and scholarly and
demmick I'm sure you'll love it or even
if you're just a plain old history buff
you've got to check this out
bill captures what it was like to live
through major events like the Berlin
Airlift the Korean War the Cuban Missile
Crisis the space race and the story ties
all of these milestones together to give
a clear picture of the apocalypse that
never happened
now if you are my age or around my age
you were not not but a glint in your
father's eye when these events were
happening the story is so well told
the setting is so brilliantly
descriptive that as you go through these
events you start to understand the
battle not only for economic freedom but
for civilization itself they've already
released two episodes of this 12 part
series so you already have some to catch
up on head on over there perfect time to
listen as the 2020 election starts to
heat up and we can see where the left
has gone completely wacko so make sure
right now to go to Daley wire.com slash
Cold War and start listening to this
incredibly important story daily
wired.com slash Cold War Andrew yang
Andrew yang has has come out and
reminded us of why no matter how fun or
wacky are out there leftists are we
cannot trust them do not be tempted
Andrew yang said something that was true
and important and interesting in this
debate over big tech censorship a key
question is whether big tech companies
are publishers or platforms so if
they're publishers then they need to be
held responsible for the content that
goes out on their platform and they can
curate and they can censor but they also
have to be responsible for a copyright
infringement intellectual property right
if they're a platform if they're just
neutral then they can't be censoring
people they can't be completely curating
and censoring their content and reang
came out on the right side of that
question he's at Facebook is acting as a
publisher but then he came to the
completely wrong conclusion here's
Andrew yang if they're watching
especially mark zuckerberg what did you
what do you say to him right now saying
mark your company is contributing to the
disintegration of our democracy if you
are an American and a patriot and you
care about
the country your kids will inherit then
you need to have Facebook step up and
say they will not be untrue political
ads on your platform whoa whoa whoa hold
on so so yang is acknowledging that
Facebook is behaving as a publisher but
his solution to that is to make Facebook
behave even more like a publisher and
kick off all the people who disagree
presumably with Andrew yang what what is
an untrue political Post there are a lot
of debates in politics politics actually
is debate and we have a self-governing
republic so that's the definition of our
politics is that we disagree about
things and politics takes place in the
debates between those different ideas if
you're going to just kick the
quote/unquote untrue political ideas off
of Facebook you are censoring half the
country you are stifling that debate you
are undermining the great American
democracy that Andrew yang says he's
trying to defend and this is the way
that all liberals seem to go when they
follow their ideas to their logical
conclusions whether they are
establishment liberals like Joe Biden or
wacky socialist liberals like Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren or techno
futurist liberals like Andrew yang it
all seems to converge on this point of
liberalism being the only valid
viewpoint and any viewpoint that
contradicts liberalism has got to be
gotten rid of
they all do it to their to different
degrees and Andrew yang is now showing
his cards he goes on well my first
preference is to sit down with a major
organization like Facebook and say hey
do the right thing but if they don't
want to do the right thing then we have
a legislature for a reason we should
just pass a law saying Facebook should
not have verifiably false political
advertisements on their platform and if
they do then they should pay a penalty
accordingly verifiably false political
advertising
what is verifiably false political
advertising if I come out and say we
need to lower taxes or the economy is
not going to
is that verifiably false I'm a lot of
liberals would say it's verifiably false
and they'll pull up a ton of Statistics
and a ton of studies to show that what I
said is verifiably false what if a
liberal comes out and says we need to
raise taxes because that'll be really
good for the economy it's that
verifiably false yeah damn right it is I
could pull out a lot of Statistics and a
lot of studies on that too then we could
debate it and argue about it
once we get past the statistics well get
down to first principles and the actual
philosophical debate that we're having
and what Andrew yang wants to do is kick
one of those points of view off of
Facebook and I suspect it's not going to
be his point of view that he's kicking
off it's probably gonna be something
closer to my point of view listen to the
way he talks about it how Cavalier he is
how would you deal with this mr. yang
look I would sit down Mark Zuckerberg
and I'd say hey buster I know you
operate a private business I know you're
trying to foster the new public square
but I need you to shut up my political
opponents all right be a good guy do me
a favor okay and then if he doesn't do
him the favor he's gonna force him
through the federal government that's
the way liberalism ends you know during
this 20-20-20 campaign conservatives
have variously flirted with different
candidates so some people got a real
kick out of Andrew yang I actually got a
real kick out of Andrew yang some people
got a kick out at Tulsi Gabbard because
Tulsi went after Hillary Clinton now
she's suing Hillary Clinton there are
other reasons that people would flirt
with Tulsi Gabbard all right she's a
she's a very interesting candidate but
let's not be mistaken here I mean
conservatives sometimes were a little
gullible were a little naive we go along
with candidates were dazzled by polish
this goes all the way back to Mitt
Romney Mitt Romney may be the most
persistent the addictive petty opponent
of the president in the whole country in
many ways more than Hillary Clinton Mitt
Romney was our Republican nominee for
president eight years ago now I knew
that was a bad idea that's why I've
worked for two of his opponents but the
GOP nominated that guy that's how duped
we were we should not allow ourselves
be duped over and over again we've got a
really nice period of conservative
governance not perfect there are certain
things that I don't agree with that the
Trump administration has done that
jailbreak bill prison reform that he
keeps touting I don't like that I think
it's a bad idea I think it's bad policy
might be smart retail politics but it
drives me nuts a few other things he's
done that I just I don't really like but
on the whole this has been the most
conservative administration in modern
times it for a hundred years or more
that's a pretty good thing I think we
should encourage those victories
especially on something as profound and
conservative and esoteric and out of
left field as making buildings beautiful
again something as simple as that we
need to encourage that that kind of
governance we need to be very wary of
these political Wolf's and sheep sheep's
clothing whether that be the kind of
eccentric liberal on the Andrew yang
side of things or whether that be the
former GOP nominee for president Mitt
Romney we have got to get to the mailbag
but first it feels like 2020 has been
going on forever like it's almost over
right truth is we're just getting
started the race for president is
heating up now and because we know that
you need to stay up to date we're giving
you 20% off all memberships that's 20%
off all memberships when using promo
code DW 2020 members get our articles ad
free access to our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show select bonus content
access to the mailbag and now election
inside op-eds
from ben shapiro plus our new all-access
tear gets you into live online Q&A
discussions with me Ben
drew Matt Walsh plus our site's writers
and special guests you ask we answer and
the leftist tears tumblr just goes glug
glug glug download The Daily wire app a
member exclusive so you can get push
notifications straight to your phone
that's promo code DW 2020 for 20% off
join today and stay informed on all
things 2020 because some boy oh boy what
a start to the year head on over to
Daley wire.com we'll be right back with
the mailbag
jumping right in because I always save
the mailbag for very last and we won't
get through enough questions so I'm
gonna burn through this mailbag from
Christopher dear Michael why do leftists
think that President Trump is trying to
destroy the Constitution all I see is
the left trying to squash free speech
cancel history take away gun rights and
install more government control I'm very
well aware of Trump derangement syndrome
but I just can't see why they think our
president is against the Constitution
thanks for all you do yes this is
puzzling to a lot of people that Nancy
Pelosi and House Democrats whose often
explicit stated purpose is to undermine
our Constitution why they're now
wrapping themselves in the Constitution
as they fight President Trump who
himself is defending the Constitution
the reason is the left is not actually
talking about the Constitution when the
left says they want to defend the
Constitution they're just using the
Constitution as a synonym for good stuff
that I like it's the same thing when the
left talks about Christianity very often
they'll make disingenuous arguments
atheist secular leftists will make these
disingenuous arguments about how
conservative Christians are failing to
live up to Christianity but the leftist
atheists don't know anything about
Christianity and they don't respect
Christianity and they don't believe it
at all they just use it as a synonym for
something good to show your own
hypocrisy it's the same way when
conservatives when liberals call
conservatives racists without any
evidence that they're racists or were
racially bigoted it doesn't matter they
don't have any evidence of it there
they're just using racist as a synonym
for bad I'll never forget there is this
left-wing commentator who went on David
Webb's radio show and called him said
that he had white privilege implied that
he was a racist and this was a problem I
guess the quote the liberal caller had
never googled David Webb because David
David Webb is a black man
but it didn't matter obviously she had
no evidence that he was some kind of
bigot she just used it to mean bad it's
a very imprecise way to use language
it's dishonest but that's what they mean
there's a kind of silver lining here
which is that at least sometimes the
left is using terms like the
Constitution as a good thing I'd rather
them say the Constitution is a good
thing even if they don't believe it
then openly come out and say that they
hate the Constitution hypocrisy is the
tribute vice pays to virtue however it
is dishonest they're not talking about
the Constitution they're not talking
about Christianity they're not they're
not talking about the things they're
talking about it's a vague good versus
bad and really what it all comes down to
is the self the cut they rewrite the
Constitution to mean whatever I want
they rewrite Christianity to mean
whatever I want it's a it's a religion
of the self and it all comes down to
pride from Elliott hi Michael I'm a big
fan thank you my question is about
reading is there a difference in benefit
between reading a physical book using a
Kindle reading on a computer or using a
book on tape audiobooks some recommend
audiobooks because you can play it at
one-and-a-half speed and absorb the most
information I have a hunch that a
physical book is best since that's been
tried and true for thousands of years
any thoughts yes I have many thoughts on
this because I read a ton of physical
books and audiobooks and ebooks it
totally depends on the book I have found
biographies are great on audiobook
they're also good if you physically read
it but you can follow follow them on
audiobook novels are not always great on
audiobook some are some aren't some
poetry you got to read them the physical
book you got to see how it's laid out on
the page but other poetry I think of you
know the foundational poems of our
civilization the Iliad and the Odyssey
ancient Greek poems
I much prefer them on audiobook because
actually that's how they were meant to
be consumed they were meant to be
performed and heard the plays of
Shakespeare you can read them maybe
that's helpful but really they're meant
to be seen in the theater it totally
depends on the particular work that
you're talking about and so I wouldn't
have a hard and fast rule for all texts
that's usually an unsuccessful way to
approach art I would do it text by text
and try the way that that makes the most
sense for that particular work from Nick
dear renowned and austere religious
podcaster who is the most overrated
American political figure bonus question
who was the worst American president
Barack Obama there's a little bit of a
recent history bias we always think that
the guy who came before is the worst and
that's just because we've recently
experienced it and then with time they
tend to look a little bit better all of
that is true except for Barack Obama he
actually is the worst president I think
in American history and I think that
history will not be very kind to him
he's also the most overrated the only
skill that he had going into the 2008
presidential election was that people
said he gave good speeches he didn't
have any other accomplishment he he
wasn't a great business leader wasn't a
great academic wasn't some great lawyer
his only credential was that he was a
community organizer whatever that means
he's just a kind of political activist
then he was in the Illinois State Senate
and he didn't barely showed up to vote
there and then he was in the US Senate
for two and a half seconds and he ran
for president and and so the only reason
that people really gave for him being
this great political figure is that he
gave good speeches but he didn't really
give very good speeches the speech that
made him famous was a speech at the
Democratic National Convention where he
said there is no such thing as a red
American a blue America black American
or white America there's the United
States of America which perfectly true I
agree with the statement but that's not
exactly soaring rhetoric it's not
exactly Abraham Lincoln it's not exactly
Pericles is it no just common sense that
he said and and frankly that was one of
the best speeches he gave he gave
another good speech when he lost he was
when he lost New Hampshire that was a
pretty good speech I mean that goes in
the in the top Obama speeches the rest
of them were not very impressive they
were meandering they were they
apologized for the country he stuttered
they were kind of boring it's an irony
is considered this great orator and the
the reality doesn't really back that up
so he
the one skill he allegedly had going in
to the presidency it just doesn't hold
up very overrated and a very bad
president from Ryan hi Michael
we ended 2019 with a debate over
internet porn that split the right
around the question of the level of
government involvement in the culture
you came out strongly against the
libertarian minded right-wingers and
supported the idea of a government that
engages the culture to promote the good
my question is the ultimate and most
important question within the debate can
the market alone provide us with enough
lives to own or does the government have
a duty and responsibility to provide us
with them as well thank you wow that is
a profound question that I did not see
it going in that direction does the
government have a role in providing us
libs to own or will the market naturally
provide enough lives to own the market
will provide lives to own this is an
area where markets are really really
efficient the government cannot get
involved in owning the lives because of
the Thirteenth Amendment we're not we're
not allowed to own people obviously
according to the government but the libs
are a sort of special case because they
offer themselves to be owned so often
and there is a no shortage of supply
here you saw this most especially this
week from the House Democrats at the
State of the Union where Nancy Pelosi
was just sitting up there muttering to
herself because the President had driven
her so crazy and you saw this in the
impeachment trial where all the Democrat
libs and that one Republican lived Mitt
Romney just got totally totally owned I
mean there were so many that even one of
the Republicans became a living God
owned this the market is doing very well
here we need to reduce regulation and
allow the invisible hand to allow us to
keep drinking from that leftist ears
tumbler from John I know you have an
appreciation for several modern movies
my question is are there any modern
music artists that you particularly
enjoy any pop music artists or songs
that you like Thanks yes very obscure
in many ways you might not expect this
for me because I'm I'm just you know I
listen mostly to classical music and old
music I love stomp cat I love Mary Ann
Hill and I love Sam shwee those are
those are pretty modern artists that I
like but that's it other than that all
classical from Jacob
greetings Michael do you think the
division between the left and the right
has any chance of being mitigated I see
a real contempt from both sides for
their opponents I'm not sure the problem
will do anything but worsen I'd love to
hear your view on this issue I see a lot
of rancor and polarization but I don't
think it's equal on both sides I think
that the left broadly seems to despise
the right Hillary Clinton admitted this
in 2016
she called the right deplorable and
irredeemable and they have doubled down
on that and they call us racists and
awful and terrible and I mean you
remember there was some kid from
Covington High School showed up on the
National Mall wearing a make America
great again hat minding his own business
starts getting verbal abuse from adults
a black supremacist and some Native
American activists banging a drum in his
face in the mainstream media pilloried
the kid said that he had the most
punchable face he ever saw so I think
the left really doesn't like the right
very much and I think the right is
bewildered by this I don't think they
have a genuine disdain or contempt for
our left-wing friends we can't
unilaterally disarm we've got to keep
fighting that cultural fight and maybe
we'd all like to get along but in in war
and in politics your opponent your
adversary gets a say in that now I do
think there will be some pushback there
will be a swing back in the other
direction a lot of that will come down
to the 2020 election if the left is
rewarded for its radical contemptuous
behavior then we'll get more of it if
the left is totally smacked down very
likely they'll change course final
question from Jeffrey dear Michael my
family is likely plagued by demons or
cursed Wow
this is a pretty heavy one to end on
okay he goes on I weep to say so but I
am related to people who have done some
frankly terrifying things to other
family members I am NOT one of those
people but
sometimes I have urges to commit
violence upon both my family and those
around me I've had these thoughts since
I was a child I've never told anyone of
these thoughts because I'm worried of
how others would think of me
I'm a deeply faithful Christian but I
sometimes doubt that I'm truly saved of
these thoughts that plagued me am I
truly saved of such dark thoughts invade
my mind at times even if I never will
act on them if not what should I do to
redeem myself all right
you should immediately go see two people
you should go see a psychologist and a
Catholic priest why because I think a
lot of people if you talk to secular
people with this problem they will
dismiss out of hand that there's any
such thing as demonic obsession or
spiritual malignant or malevolence right
they'll say oh no that's all just
made-up fantasy stuff you've just got
some psychological problems to only deal
with it that way now if you deal with
some people who are religiously
eccentric or zealous they might say oh
psychology is a bunch of bunk this is
all spiritual so go just deal with the
spiritual part the reality is that the
human person is both spirit soul and
body and I don't know which it is in
your case and you don't know which it is
and that's why you need professional
help so I would go and first
try to make sure that this is not just a
psychological problem that you can work
out through through therapy or through
some other intervention then you should
speak to a Catholic priest
I say Catholic priest because the
Catholics have a long track record here
so even if you were not Catholic
yourself they've got a long track record
thinking about these kind of spiritual
questions and I think that would be
helpful to you and you probably get the
most information that way because there
is more between heaven and earth than
are dreamt of in our philosophy and also
medical modern medical science has
advanced to a point that you hopefully
will be able to diagnose these things
you're not going to diagnose them though
by keeping them to yourself or even just
talking to me you'll have to talk to
people who are expert in that question
so I wish you the best of luck and have
courage both physical courage and
spiritual
all right that's our show I am coming
back to lala land flying back to the
west coast you should check out the
latest episode of my podcast with
Senator Ted Cruz verdict to hear about
the future of that podcast and in the
meantime I will see you on Monday I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show the Michael Noel's show is
produced by Ben Davies director Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer Austin
Stevens assistant director
Pavel madoski editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show well with Iowa
the State of the Union now Trump's
acquittal the Democrats have had their
worst week since Appomattox
we will mock them and hear the
lamentations of their women the Andrew
Klavan show on the Andrew Klay